let's see if we can take the
antiderivative of x squared times e to
the X DX now the key is to recognize
when you can at least attempt to use
integration by parts and it might be a
little bit obvious because this video is
about integration by parts but the one
way to the clue that integration by
parts may be applicable is to say look
I've got a function that's the product
of two other functions in this case x
squared and e to the X and integration
by parts can be useful as if I can take
the derivative of one of them and it
becomes simpler and if I take the
antiderivative of the other one it
becomes no more complicated so in this
case if I were to take the
antiderivative of x squared it does
become simpler and it becomes 2x and if
I take the antiderivative of e to the X
it doesn't become any more complicated
so let's assign f of X to be equal to x
squared and we want that one to be the
one where if I take the derivative
become simpler because I'm gonna have to
take the derivative of f of X right over
here and the integration by parts
formula and let's assign G prime of X
let's assign G prime of X to be equal to
e to the X because later I'm gonna have
to take its antiderivative and the
antiderivative of e to the X is still
just e to the X so let me write this
down
so we are assigning we are saying that f
of X I'll do it right over here f of X
is equal to x squared
in which case f prime of X is going to
be equal to 2x and I'm not worrying
about its cot the constants right now
we'll just add a constant at the end to
make sure that our antiderivative is in
the most general form and then G prime
of X G prime of X is equal to e to the X
which means its antiderivative G of X is
still equal to e to the X and now we're
ready to apply this the right hand side
right over here so all this this thing
right over here is going to be equal to
f of X which is x squared and let me put
it right underneath x squared times G of
X which is e to the X which is e to the
X minus - the let me do that in that
yellow color I want to make the colors
match up - the antiderivative of F prime
of X well F prime of X is 2x
to X times G of X G of X is e to the X G
of X is e to the X DX e to the X DX so
you might say Sal we're left with
another another antiderivative another
indefinite integral right over here how
do we do how do we solve this one and as
you might guess the key might be
integration by parts again and we're
making progress this right over here is
a simpler expression than this notice we
were able to reduce the degree of this x
squared and now is just a 2x so let's
actually and what we can do to simplify
this a little bit since 2 is just a
scaler it's a constant it's multiplying
the function we can take that out of the
integral sign so let's take it this way
so let me rewrite it this way we can
only do that with a constant that's
multiplying the function so let me put
the 2 right out here and so now what
we're concerned about is finding the
integral let me write it right over here
the integral of X e to the X DX and now
this is another integration by parts
problem and so let's again let's again
apply the same principles of integration
by parts and what I take as derivatives
going to get simpler well X is going to
get simpler when I take its derivative
so now for the purposes of integration
by parts let's redefine f of X to be
equal to just X and then we can still
have G of X equaling we are G prime of X
equaling e to the X and so in this case
let me write it all down f of X is equal
to X F prime of X is equal to 1 G prime
of X G prime of X is equal to e to the X
G of X is equal to just the
antiderivative of this is equal to e to
the X so let's apply integration by
parts again so this is going to be equal
to f of X times G of X now f of X is X f
of X is X G of X is e to the X e to the
X minus minus the antiderivative of F
prime of X well that's just 1
times G of X e to the X is just 1 times
e to the X 1 times e to the X e to the X
DX D X and remember all I'm doing right
now you might have lost track of things
I'm just focused on this antiderivative
that antiderivative is that
antiderivative there if we can figure
out what it is we can then substitute
back into our original expression now
you might appreciate integration by
parts what does this right over here
simplify to what is the antiderivative
of 1 times e to the X DX or or what is
the antiderivative 1 times e to the X
well it's just the antiderivative of e
to the X which is just e to the X so
this simplifies to X eat it times e to
the x times e to the X minus the
antiderivative of e to the X which is
just e to the X so minus e to the X and
then we can take this and substitute it
back this is the antiderivative of this
so we can substitute it back up here to
figure out the antiderivative of our
original expression so the
antiderivative of our original
expression we're getting really close is
going to be equal to and let me use it's
going to be equal to I'm gonna use
different colors so we can keep track of
things it's going to be equal to x
squared times e to the X x squared times
e to the X minus 2 minus 2 times all of
this business so minus 2 times well this
antiderivative we just figured out is
this minus 2 times X e to the X minus e
to the X and if we want now is a good
time to put our plus C and of course we
can simplify this this is equal to x
squared I like to keep the same colors
this is equal to x squared e to the X
distribute the negative two you get
minus 2x e to the X plus 2 e to the X
and then finally and then finally plus C
and we're done we figured out the
antiderivative of what looked like a
kind of hairy
looking expression using integration by
parts twice